il s'est passé quelque chose
d'exceptionnel hier puisque touche pas à
mon poste a franchi toutes les
frontières alors d'habitude c'est vrai
qu'on était comparé aux autres
toxo et là ça y est les américains nous
regarde
oh
non
il y à un incident diplomatique
énorme avec les états unis sachez le ils
en ont même fait appel au président de
la république à françois hollande est
pour eux celui qu'il faut vendre tout ce
couple on a un nom mokhtar
ici s'expliquer avec camille combal ce
sera aux alentours de 19h20 dans touche
pas à mon poste pour accueillir tout de
suite camille combal et rockstar pour la
polémique
chers téléspectateurs
si vous nous rejoignez ça cherche pas à
mon poste a franchi des limites
touche pas à mon poste affranchi des
frontières touche pas à mon poste est
devenue une émission culte aux états
unis grâce ou à cause de mokhtar et
camille combal un animateur américain un
des plus grands franchement il y aura
une meuf trois immenses animateurs qui
s'appelle conan o'brian quand on voit la
la qu'est ce qui s'est passé camille
combal est ce que vous pouvez cliquer au
temps colonial on a su que ça allait
couler beaucoup dans sa fait couler
énormément d'encre on a on est tous fans
ici de conan o'brian oui et il avait
fait un truc quelques temps qu'ils
étaient les tutos mais on s'en est
jamais caché on a dit et on va le faire
avec moctar môme la môme au clash
essayer ça pourrait être amusant nom
n'est pas prévu que monsieur était
devenu une star aux etats unis elle
tunisiano est regardée outre atlantique
et du coup bas conan o'brian a vu les
dents tôt et il en a parlé qu'elle dans
l'émission et c'est une émission mais
j'ai même pas vous dire à quel point
elle écoute aux états unis sur tibi est
aussi un truc de dingue de lui c'est
comme ici
motus motus alors regardez donc
l'animateur américain qui parle de nous
après vous aurez vos explications vous
allez tous nous lire et il nous fait et
c'est la vidéo
camille on voit la vidéo où ils nous
demandent des choses ou pas ça c'est
après on voit la vidéo il passe le sait
qu'en santé aux états unis et qui fait
que mokhtar aujourd'hui persona non
grata sont là bas sur le continent
américain mais tous les bacs vous des
gouttes alors là je peux vous le dire
regardez ce qui s'est passé hier aux
états unis on a parlé de touche pas à
mon poste
quand les shooters des moteurs sur le
french woman show tu prends à mon procès
terville et ça n'est pas terminé et nous
a fait une requête qui est qu'on va voir
dans un instant mechali elle a été très
très loin cette histoire déjà je trouve
qu'ils parlent mal de fous beau car si
je perds ça on est on ferme l'incident
diplomatique mais ce qui m'a un peu des
plus si je peux me permettre avec tout
le respect que j'ai pour conan c'est
qu'ils s'en est pris à cyril non à bas
prix c'est carrément foutu de la gueule
de siècle ça j'ai moins aimé regarder
quoi il s'est foutu de ma gueule c'est
foutu de la gueule c'est voulu nano
brillant là le rock alors ok nous c'est
foutu pakala pour un tournage qui s'y
attendait vous savez les images j'ai des
images on les verra dans un instant vous
avez votre réponse
on a une réponse on aime on aime un
moteur qui veut partir faire une
carrière américaine dont tu voudrais
s'adresser aux états unis dont on a tous
acquis avec vous allez vous adresser aux
états unis dans un instant également
mokhtar on va revenir sur toute cette
affaire on vous donnera toutes les
explications parce que camille combal a
été roulée dans la boue
1le tunisiano également le mokhtaria
également on vous dira tout ça dans un
instant et on reviendra ça va cd v cali
camille combal camille combal et mokhtar
vous et à
si vous nous rejoignez sur des beats
sachez que tous pas mon poste a franchi
les frontières
touche pas à mon poste on parle de nous
aux états unis et on nous accuse de
plagiat camille combal et mokhtar
mokhtar est au centre de toutes les
attentions aux états unis faut savoir
que si vous arrivez aux états unis que
ce soit à los angeles à new york à
washington ou à madrid ne dit pas
mokhtar voilà c'est le le mokhtar gates
quoi voilà c'est ça en est exactement
alors qu'abby donc l'animateur qu'on a
vu dans conan o'brian qui est une
immense star aux états gênant mais
énorme a donc bien de parler de mokhtari
là ne parlait de touche pas à mon poste
qu'est ce qui se passe
il ya un autre extrait qu'est-ce qui
veut que ce pays continue de montrer
l'extrait de l'émission et là vraiment
je n'aime pas parce qu'il s'en prend un
petit peu à vous ils sont trois mois il
va n'a pleuré à moi aussi nous tous
finalement mais ouais il prend un peu
survolé ça c'est le seul moment où
peut-être un peu je suis sorti de mes
gongs
alors qu'amy est ce que vous avez volé à
ce que mokhtar a volé est-ce que vous
n'aurez jamais moi si je suis là
aujourd'hui c'est pour que mokhtar
puisse à nouveau rentrer sur le
territoire américain parce qu'il craint
grande carrière
mais c'est vrai et sachez que non alors
non là on a vu les mais on a vu les
tutoz sur internet ne s'en est jamais
caché on a dit bravo à conan de regarder
la version de conan et même à mai et il
rit voilà non non c'est très drôle à
part quand ils demandent des choses un
petit peu impossible
qu'est-ce qu'il a demandés et des
exigences série on a essayé d'y répondre
au maximum on a fait que ça toute la
journée la chronique de faim s'en
ressentira forcément mais voilà on a
répondu
regardez déjà les exigences du grand
caudal voilà tout ce qu'il a voulu faire
garder un petit peu tout ce qu'il veut
qu'on fasse pour lui pour se faire
pardonner pour pâques et le drame entre
la france et l'espagne
aucun domaine en france
vraiment la savak c'est loin alors
qu'annie tombale on a des soucis alors
accès là quelques roquettes alors pour
la statue on est un peu short dans la
journée et la statue au jardin du
luxembourg on a fait notre match mais je
peux déjà annoncer akono brain on a déjà
réussi au moins a coiffé la regarder la
tour eiffel avec la même coupe que conan
pour lui rendre hommage vous allez voir
regarder ce qu'on a mis au goût ça a été
fait cet après midi là comme ça c'est un
petit peu le longer le répertoire bien
fourni
j'ai eu françois hollande à l'époque
garde à une heure il y a près une heure
et il a été et voilà il a pris la parole
en direct de l'elysée pour s'excuser
pour l'estrie sylla en sorte
voilà que ça fasse pas dans tous les
sens avec eux que cette incision
diplomate s'actionne maintien au calme
alors c'est très bien mais c'est qui la
peluche à côté de toi depuis tout à
l'heure par dota a des choses à dire aux
états unis ce sera dans un instant mais
juste avant on a le discours du
président de la république françois
hollande s'est exprimé sur cet incident
regardez écoutez mes chers compatriotes
les récents événements survenus dans tpb
ont mis en péril les bonnes relations
entre la france et les états unis
mokhtar et mon souci c'est pour moi un
agent de sécurité hors pair
c'est pourquoi j'invite officiellement
monsieur konan breuil collines comme je
connais de o'brian en france pour qu'ils
discutent ensemble
je garderai le chercher moi-même en
scooter des poteaux à vous tous
on veut pas avoir des soucis avec
nicolas canteloup demain on sait qu il
le fait sur tf1 sa part a des soucis
avec tout le monde à bord plus sachez
que camille combal à une nouvelle
séquence à nous dévoiler tout à l'heure
tout à l'heure avec moctar on a essayé
de continuer mais alors vraiment cette
fois ci on innove taille et voilà vous
avez vous avez décidé d'innover juste
avant mokhtar voulez vous adresser aux
américains alors vous avez crié trop
connaître puisque je sais vous êtes
bilingue ici à kaunas vous vous adressez
à conan o'brian donc l'animateur
américain qui qui venait à des liens
accusé de plagiat
alice konan konan regardez bien cette
caméra konan aller à mokhtar forme le
tuto allender ça doit te dit sur moi
haye a motivé frères ayew bilingue en
anglais connue quand tu peux or les deux
font style économe
la suite est connue sartec les tutos
je pense que si conan non regardez vous
avez vu on est regardé aux états unis
c'est comme ça nous arrive à croire les
gars vous rendez pas compte pour nous
c'est vraiment une année ses créations
est donc là bas donc il vous regardez ça
donc vous avez tout fait c'est
maintenant vous avez décidé de tout
remettre à plat
vous avez une nouvelle séquence à nous
proposer avec moctar une séquence
vraiment inédit voilà vu nulle part ça
arrivera demain on a un petit teasing de
ce que va donner mais vraiment voilà on
voulait repartir sur de bonnes bases et
c'est terminé tout c'est vous avez
trouvé l'idée n'a jamais vu - c'est plus
mokhtar mais enfin jessica sa santé
quand ça sent le nouveau comme ça
enfonce voilà aller comme ça tout est
remis à plat regarder et camille combal
et ça pour le coup c'est de lits dédiés
regarde sécurité sécurité des émissions
bonjour oui bonjour je vous appelle en
fait parce que je suis fan d'attention à
la marche et j'aurais aimé savoir
comment on assiste à l'émission ben
c'est tout ça tu vois la tanzanie tu as
tout droit à droite après toi te faire
[ __ ] ailleurs super ambiance
c'est
ah bon
locale et tous